それじゃあ始めちゃうで質疑でここ3億円
の豪邸の蔵にはなんですけれども思ったん
ですよ
広いと買った時から思ってたんですけど
以上に広いと恐怖すら感じるとこの広さ
広い広い広い広い広い全部私ど
には広すぎてちょっとびっくりしてるん
ですけどもはじめの王女皆さんこんなに
広かったら衝撃的なものを着るんじゃない
かと思いましてこんなヤバイものをいくつ
か準備させていただきました何かといい
ますとバルーン遊具ってわかりませんだ
バローバルーン言っていうのはイベントと
お祭でひときわ大きい遊具見たことあり
ませんかね子供たちだったんです入るよう
ななく超巨大なバルーンね空気ダメ着先は
になる優遇んですけどもはやそんな
イベントとか祭りで使われるような重大な
施設を何個かほどほらにおけるだけ置いて
みようと思います朝した子なんですよこれ
がターゲットはですねこの寒気の家を管理
してくれる第1款このような還元議員が
ターゲットなのでハンディ人がこのうちに
来る前にこの朝5のうちに業者さんや佐賀
お願いしましてこちらに巨大な施設をツン
なを切るだけ置いてくださいとお願いした
んでそこ今からすごいことになると思うん
であの楽しみだねアノール3面から
ぱどんたより大がかりだなぁ
ターゲット使って入ってくるんだよ聞いた
僕2つとかのおは d カンちゃおっこう
いう見た目その頑張ってくればそうですね
ちょっ
いい
はいプレゼント
[音楽]
ふぇすてぃばれ
た
wh
me
ん
he ん
ana
car
ええええええrarame
ni
car
dee
大闘技であれから一時間半くらい経ちまし
た怖いよ
さっきまで何もなかったよねー
ちょっと嫌がったん
パッチパックあった
ちょっと浮い号
ちょっとここでさぁ
にバイオ
パパっ方
うわぁ凄いねこれさぁ人んちの庭よ自分ち
のには自分つんにはよけど技よくある
じゃんあのイベントとかお祭りとかでこの
子どもたちが結構遊ぶでか遊具なんとなく
日当でさあこうやって探してたらなんか
レンタルできるのかっておっちゃんっ
思ったらうっちこっといっぱい出てくるん
じゃねと思って今回頼んでみましたぁーっ
うーんたちがああああああ
やりすぎたね浦戸すごーい遺尿夢よ廃墟
遊戯で裏庭に初めてはバッグからせデー
[音楽]
ていた
と
以下例をパスが覚めリコいくが売っ
ちゃおう
だったら温暖化
マシーンだ
[音楽]
こういうデザイン科のてさんあるまっけん
すけなおい高いのだ
[音楽]
みーて見て見て見て
ません
名前け
どうしよう
言えと動く大もうすごいこれじゃあ子ども
たちよ見たかったねなんで28歳の俺が
一人で楽しいんだろう
いい運動になったはもうじゃあ次はねぇ
こんな総合格闘技のステージみたいとか
行こうかいっどっパパパーク me
持って行くたところ
ん
こんなにカラーボールとかを入れて
3つ跳ねるみたいです
なる本園今日は母ボールでいいからここで
後輩たちにとっています大
今日の試合は計付きない朝からみくる
yeah 後輩ジャケ付きが見てください
大ところ座でございます俺が見てきたクマ
のぬいぐるみです史上最強サインですよ
間違えないことだ
以下春よ
pane
[音楽]
noneパンツすごいガッツくれるいい
いいいい
あああああっ欲しいんだよねー
足をレイクで処理できてるし俺じゃなかっ
たはい俺どうやって来座は早いなぁやっぱ
空気リオすごいんだろうな結構見てはこれ
もこれもこれまぁそんなから直径いまでや
べーなんでいきましょうちゃんとやすい
からて2をつくっていたけどどっ小さい
じゃないけどいやーこれ
4 dk レンガの家やな5分が入ってみ
ましょうか
[音楽]
car
だよもう分かってるって芸術家の妹じゃ
ええええさっきじゃんあっ火を消し日本人
もいた応用
[音楽]
ファギー対するカーン
結局ばさっきにまずは直結してこれ多分
一番いいやつです今みてくださいはいそれ
キャンディそしてこの超巨大滑り台ですね
熱い練ってるこーいこーやばいよってい
ますし
くれあずれ
見てこれだってもう何もアダプタウンサー
俺が裏地は22今や回覧ができ滑り台が
できるってさバルーンいうのか文字を漢字
読めますってちょっと行けます
麺処やりましたらどうぞ
グッチた役立ちた
キュルッシェネイ本当にしたどんどん
フリース着なれば寒いしてなきゃいけ
[音楽]
いやもう minimi なく階段がお
すごいすごいすごいやーこのそびえ立つ
キャンディそしてこっちからこの高さで
いい見ることないからなーいやーすごい
なぁ
入っているいかがでしょうか昼夜これを
すごいよグラディアの可能性を感じても
こんなたくさんさああのイベントだがお
祭りで使われる子どもたちがそれと受ける
と思ってなかったんです4つ電子から本題
は9分から格好だとこの家のアンミニ
リュウお任せているアゲートの第二軍が
来るんですけどもの香り果てた裏にはを見
て何をほぼでしょうかというと時間待ち
ましょう
[音楽]
半田遊園地
お化け屋敷園バッジ遊園地2
ゆっが遊園地遊園チューブ遊園地に通知さ
8ドル姉あえず
ファイネスト今日は遊園じゃあ遊園地遊園
地遊園地きたよそう入園家だよなんか次音
の聞こえるとあの誘致だから時いろいろ今
主題が3階なんだよ
何やるか彦はブーン
この想いはないで初便の
わっはっは
ああああああ
ございますはい
新たにと管理に今年一年ありがとうござい
ましたあいえませんそとてもとを使ったん
でちょっとテーマパークに手をバースが
使ったらもうちょい前でてもらってもっ
ちゃうもうちょい待ちます
まあそれは協議文書はモテませんよ
持っん
いやー
たちにとっていいよ
用語ぞ
はに言い j 抜きさっほー
ほど母港枠はじゃあまず言え粘って撮っ
てるだって三
[拍手]
[音楽]
voodooなんか全然分からなかった
ちょっと見てみてくださいこっちからねぇ
あっはぁん
ああああああ